ich glaube die ereignisse der letzten
tage haben aber allen deutlich gemacht
das ist jetzt notwendig ist alles dafür
zu tun dass es zu keiner eskalation
kommt dazu ist es auch in den letzten
tagen nicht gekommen und vor allen
dingen dem politischen prozess wieder
aufzusetzen darüber bin ich mit meinem
französischen kollegen sehr einig das
werden wir heute mit allen hier
besprechen und auch darüber reden die
dieser prozess wieder in gang gesetzt
werden kann
und vor allen dingen auch das muss man
sehen ob es einem gefällt oder nicht
ohne russland wird man diesen konflikt
nicht lösen können jetzt geht es darum
den weg zu beschreiben wie das was wir
alle erreichen wollen erstens einen
waffenstillstand die zugang für
humanitäre leistung dass wir eine
übergangsregierung in syrien brauchen
das ist letztlich auch eine
verfassungsreform geben muss am schluss
irgendwann war
denn es müssen sich alle menschen in
syrien mit einer lösung anfreunden
könnten und das müssen auch die russen
wissen die bisher nur die hat über das
assad regime
es wird eine lösung erst mal geben mit
all denen die einfluss haben in der
region ist jemand der chemie waffen
gegen seine bevölkerung einsetzt ein
teil dieser lösung sein kann
das kann sich wohl niemand vorstellen